mais c'est jacques à et mélanie doutey
gérard jugnot
c'est beaucoup la wii c'est beaucoup
moins dense et méritée en tout cas ça
fait plaisir
la dernière fois vous êtes venu gérard
jugnot vous étiez accompagné d'adriana
karembeu
oui c est ce que vous seriez le nouveau
séducteur du cinéma français plus connus
on fonce dessus
oui c'est vrai vous connaissez papa
maman bien je souhaitais dans le métier
absolument depuis c'est dans ce métier
ça n'empêche rien on est ici ce soir
pour un film adapté d'une pièce de
musset il ne faut jurer de rien c'est un
film d'eric si lannion avec vous deux et
jean dujardin qui sort mercredi prochain
le 28 septembre
voilà le pitch b oui parce que quand
même
donc gérard est un riche commerçant jean
dujardin 109e mène une vie dissolue
l'alcool les femmes le jeu sur le compte
de son oncle c'est là que vous gerin
décidé de le marier à mélanie qui est
issu d'une famille aristocratique mais
qui roule pas sur l'or
parce que vous voulez ajouter à votre
fortune quelques titres de noblesse mais
jean dujardin votre neveu n'a aucune
envie de se marier et ils parient qu'il
peut facilement séduire mélanie en 24
heures est donc prouvé qu'elle ne mérite
pas d'être aînés mais mélanie croit à
l'amour et vous allez vous révéler
beaucoup plus difficile à conquérir que
prévu se rendre à tonner but voilà assez
formidable s'il ya un mot par fish
ça lui permet le lundi de 10 heures ce
week end a fait 400 fait voilà c'est
vrai nom mais vous n'hésitez pas à aller
à l'encontre de ce que vous demande
votre mère est en fait vous refusez de
vous laisser séduire facilement parce ce
jean dujardin voilà surtout cécile est
un personnage qui est qui a envie
d'aimer la personne de choisir la
personne qu'elle va aimer quoi est donc
là on le sent qu'on essaie de lui
imposer quelqu'un et c'est ce qu'elle
redoute le plus
donc ce qui était très moderne pour
l'époque quoi c'est même un peu
féministe un peu féministe elle
revendique de choisir sa vie c'est un
peu george sand se pose d'ailleurs un
moment elle s'habille en leur mac deux
hommes cette filiation
souvenez-vous comme que tout en haut du
corps d'une femme il y en tête
ah oui pour les gens qui pensent comme
ça non mais c'est vrai que là on est en
train de parler de sueur sur des choses
assez grave
ce qui m'amène ou paix dans le film mais
en plus cela j'ai eu parce que j'ai
toujours un peu en province voire
écouter les salles on a vraiment les
gens sortent avec la banane viennent
comme ça qu'est ce qu'ils savent pas
trop ce qu'ils vont voir
et puis sortent vraiment très heureux
parce que les costumes les carrosses des
trucs qui sont elles les jours minable